the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so today I want us to go more in depth
into the photon interactions with matter
and we're going to bring the theory back
to something that we can actually start
to use in doing shielding calculations
if you want to find out how much of this
material
do I need to shield this much gammas
we're gonna answer that question today
first I want to start off again with
compton scattering because I messed up a
couple of the energy things from last
time I got excited
due to an energetic coincidence between
the photo peak and the continent of our
banana spectrum and one of the examples
in the book so I'm going to correct that
now and we'll go through in more
mathematical detail why that wasn't the
case and what the actual quirk of
physics is because there is a constant
energy thing here that I want to
highlight to you guys so skipping ahead
on the photoelectric effect which I
think was similar to review compton
scattering it's the same thing that we
saw between two particles except now one
of them's a photon and like I said on
the next homework after quiz 1 you guys
will be doing the balance between energy
and momentum because the photons don't
really have mass in order to figure out
what's the relationship between the
incoming energy of the photon the
outgoing energy of the photon and the
recoil energy of the electron and so
this is these are the relationships we
were showing last time it's it's is an
interesting quirk of physics that the
wavelength shift itself does not depend
on the energy of the photon coming in as
you can see it just depends on the angle
that it scatters at and a bunch of
constants where that M right there is
stands for mass of the electron
now that wavelength shift while that
wavelength shift does not depend on the
energy of the incoming photon the recoil
energy does you can see it depends on
both the energy and the angle and the
incoming energy of the photon equals H
nu and to give that quick primer on
photon things I want to show you guys
here why that's the case so even if you
have a constant wavelength shift that
might give you a non constant energy
shift so even though in this Compton
scattering formula the wavelength shift
only matters with the angle the energy
shift actually depends on the angle and
the incoming energy of the photon so now
let's look at a couple
of limiting cases so as we have a of the
photon equals H nu goes to zero what
does t approach the recoil energy of the
electron well let's just do out the
formula right this recoil energy equals
H nu which is the energy of the incoming
gamma times 1 minus cosine theta over MC
squared over H nu plus 1 minus cosine
theta as H nu approaches 0 what happens
here ya H nu goes to 0 this fraction
goes to infinity and this goes to 0
hopefully that's an intuitive
explanation if the incoming photon has
zero energy it can transfer zero energy
to the electron now the more interesting
case what happens now as a gamma
approaches infinity as the photon gets
higher and higher in energy
do you approach this almost H do I
actually want to do a quick calculation
without doing all the limit math let's
say we had energy of the gamma was 1 GeV
and extremely high energy so all we plug
in and let's say we wanted to find out
what's the maximum energy of this recoil
electron and this is something I want to
ask you guys I can't remember yesterday
did we say that T is a maximum at theta
equals PI or PI over 2 what did we say
yesterday interesting it's PI actually
the case where you have the largest
energy transfer and sorry for not
catching that is just like in a nuclear
collision if the photon were to back
scatter it transfers the maximum energy
to the electron so the analogy here is
like perfect between two particles
hitting and between a photon and a
particle hitting the maximum energy is
when theta equals PI and let's actually
plug that in to find out why if we say T
max equals H nu depends on the electron
coming in 1 minus cosine theta over MC
squared over H nu plus 1 minus cosine
theta at theta equals PI cosine theta
goes to minus 1 and so then that also
goes to minus 1 and so this becomes 2 H
nu over MC squared over H nu plus 2 and
so that without worrying about the
numerator especially in the limit of
very high-energy photons you can see
that that actually maximizes the recoil
energy of the electron the reason we're
harping so much on this recoil energy of
the electron is because that's what we
measure so when we look at our banana
spectrum you're not measuring the energy
of the photon you're measuring the
recoil energy of the electron and the
ionization cascade that happens as all
those electrons smash into each other
creating electron hole pairs which are
counted
is current if you guys remember from
last class in fact I'll just bring up
the blackboard image because we can do
that so I took a picture of the board
yesterday photon interactions part one
there it is we'll just use the screen as
a bigger blackboard for now so if you
guys remember let's say a gamma ray
comes in and causes a Compton scattering
nth or a photoelectric emission or
whatever it doesn't matter which process
and it liberates an electron either by
scattering off of it or just getting
absorbed and ejecting it or it doesn't
really matter how but it creates this
electron hole pair that electron right
here has this recoil energy which
depends on theta the angle that it
scatters and the incoming energy and
that electron is going to keep moving in
this material knocking into other
electrons very very efficiently so that
most of the energy of that electron
recoil actually gets counted as other
electrons being freed we're going to go
over on well next Friday electron
nuclear interactions including what's
the probability and energy transfer when
electrons slam into each other or when
ions slam into electrons or each other
see so let me go back to the slides and
so this maximum as you approach as this
approaches infinity this actually
approaches a value of H nu minus 0.25 5
MeV just to do the quick calculation to
give a numerical example if I plug in
theta equals PI and H nu equals 1 Giga
electron volt or a thousand MeV and
could anyone remind me what is mm mass
of the electron C squared what's the
rest mass of the electron sorry
right while I'm usually against
memorizing anything because that's what
like books in the internet are for this
is one of those quantities that I want
on the tip of your tongue as nuclear
engineers you should remember what the
rest mass of the electron is because a
lot of our cow quantities are calculated
based upon it
for example this ratio Emmys it was at h
nu / m ec squared gives you the energy
the photon in terms of the number of
electron rest masses which is a useful
quantity in itself so what am i plug all
this stuff in so we have 0.5 1 1 over a
thousand plus 2 flipped over the x-axis
times 2 times H nu and we get so that T
becomes nine ninety-nine point seven
four five MeV interestingly enough
thousand MeV are in going photon - that
equals that right there so that's the
interesting quirk of physics is as you
as the photon increases in energy the
maximum amount of energy that it can
leave with or the sorry the minimum
amount of energy the photon can leave
with or the maximum amount it can impart
to an electron approaches 0.255 MeV or
the photon energy - that what do you
guys notice about that number
that's right it's exactly half the rest
mass of the electron so as your photons
hit the GeV range and above they can all
leave with half the rest mass of the
electron of energy which means you have
more and more energy able to be
transferred in a given Compton scatter
as the photon gets higher and higher in
energy so for the limit of low energy
the photons basically bounce off without
transferring much energy at all and the
higher energy the photon gets the higher
percentage of that maximum transfer can
be so that's what I wanted to clarify
from last time it was an interesting
coincidence that our photo peak and our
Compton edge were pretty close to that
number apart but one MeV isn't quite
infinity what it is pretty close that
difference right there what does that
come out to before I say something
stupid I'll just
calculate it two for one
it's like 0.218 MeV so we're already
most of the way there so once you reach
like 10 or 100 MeV you're pretty much at
that limit and so what that tells you is
that the dif the distance between a
photo peak and it's corresponding
Compton edge for high-energy photons is
going to be half the rest mass of the
electron once you get to lower and lower
energies that distance will start to
shrink
I'm sorry other way around that distance
will start to grow and I have a few
examples I want to show you but first in
order to understand these now I want to
get into the part I told you we get to
yesterday which is what's the
probability that a confidence got R
happens at a certain angle and this
polar plot explains it pretty well in
the limit of really low photons like
0.01 MeV or 10 ke V photons you can see
that this forward scattering to an angle
of zero or back scattering to an angle
of 180 there's a 180 that's blocked by
an axis right there they're almost the
same so forward and back scattering
there's not really that much of a big
difference in probability so we were
going to start graphing theta of this
Compton's scatter as a function of the
going to introduce this new quantity
this angular ly dependent cross section
before we were giving you cross-sections
in the form of just Sigma's like Sigma
Compton now we're actually telling you
what's the probability of that
interaction happening in this certain
angle so it's called the differential
cross section and you can have all sorts
of differential cross sections like
energy differential cross sections angle
differential cross sections whatever
have you so if we try and graph what is
the shape of this look like this polar
plot on a more understandable graph we
can see that the probability is pretty
high let's just call that a relative
probability of one and as we trace
around this circle that value gets lower
and lower until we hit 90 degrees or PI
over two at which point it starts to pop
back up almost to its original value so
this was for a 10k evey Photon
now let's take a different extreme
example we have a three MeV photon right
here and that's that long dashed curve
so that one here in the center so we can
see that the relative probability of
zero degrees is the same and if we trace
around to 180 we're almost at the origin
which tells us that for three MeV it
starts off the same and quickly drops
really far down what that means is that
what's called forward scattering is
preferred
so up on this board we were talking
about what's the maximum energy that a
photon can transfer which is always in
the back scattering case the other part
to note is that that back scattering
probability gets lower and lower as the
photon gets higher and higher in energy
yeah exactly
yeah the cross-section value will yeah
goes down as you increase in energy so a
total forward scatter if you had a true
forward scatter where theta equals zero
I'll call that a miss it means that
because we saw in this formula up here
when when theta equals zero there is no
energy transfer nothing and so that that
would be to me like a Miss if that
angles ever so slightly above zero then
there is some scattering but there's
very little energy transfer
but that smaller energy transfer becomes
more likely when the photon goes higher
in energy these are these sorts of like
cause-and-effect relationships I want
you guys to be able to reason out if I
were to give you a polar plot of this
differential cross-section with angle
and energy I want you to be able to
reproduce this and tell me what's really
going on if we fill in one of the ones
in between let's go with 0.2 MeV this
sort of single dashed line you can see
that the probability of backscattering
is somewhere between the three MeV and
the ten ke V yeah Luke
that's right backscattering refers to
the photon going back which means this
situation were the difference in angle
between the incoming and outgoing photon
is PI 180 degrees which means it just
turns around and moves the other way
right so that dashed line right there
would follow something like this at what
did we say 0.2 MeV
the form the full form of this cross
section right here is referred to as the
Cline Nisshin a cross section and it has
been derived by quantum electrodynamics
which I will not derive for you now but
there are plenty of derivations online
if that's your kind of thing and I had
to make a trade off in this class of how
deep do we go into each concept versus
how many concepts do we teach and I'm
going for the latter because if there's
any course that's supposed to give you
an overview of nuclear's 2201 there will
be plenty of time for quantum in 2202
and beyond so do you want at any rate
this is the general form of it and what
this actually tells you is that as the
energy of the photon increases the
effect of that angle well you're gonna
die you guys will have to work that out
on a homework problem I just remembered
I want to stop stealing your thunder and
giving away half the homework yep
yes
the quantity D Sigma D Omega says let's
say you have a photon coming in at our
x-axis you've got an electron here
what's the probability that it scatters
off into some small a area D Omega so in
some small D Phi or sorry D theta D Phi
or some small sine theta D theta D Phi
into an element of solid angle
I should probably draw that smaller to
be a little more differential looking so
if gammas are gonna scatter off in all
directions but this D Sigma D Omega
tells you what's the probability that it
goes through that little patch
so that that Omega has some component of
theta in it and some component of Phi in
it since it's a solid angle it depends
on both the angle of rotation and the
angle of inclination which we call theta
and Phi now to get from this to the
regular cross-section you're used to you
can integrate over all angles Omega of
the differential cross-section and
you'll get the regular total
cross-section which is just what is the
probability of Compton scattering . if
you wanted to know then what's the
probability of Compton scattering into
this angle it sounds kind of boring
right why do we care about the angle
anyone bored yet you can raise your
hands be honest interesting okay well
I'm gonna tell you why it's not boring
cuz I don't think you're honest you can
actually if you know the angle at which
a Compton photon scatters into actually
I want to leave that stuff up there is a
pretty much one-to-one relation between
the energy and the angle of scattering
which means that let's say you have a
cargo container and inside and your arms
are you don't have a cargo container you
have a cargo ship full of tons and tons
of these stacked up cargo containers has
anyone actually ever seen one of these
before I'm gonna okay in case not I'm
gonna do something dangerous and go to
the Internet and hopefully the search
for cargo container doesn't come up with
something disgusting oh look at that
how about cargo container [ __ ] yeah okay
you got one of these right and your
detector goes off and it just says
there's something radioactive that
shouldn't be here how do you find out
which container it's in without taking
the ship apart interesting problem huh
do you just kind of look yeah
that's one way you could shield you
could mask off the ship and move your
detector around and then do it for the
other two dimensions so that will get
you there but slowly how do you do it
quickly well you do it with the client
ition a cross-section if you know the
relationship between the energy and the
angle of a Compton scatter you take two
detectors detector one detector two and
you form what's called a Compton camera
this is awesome because with two
detectors you can pinpoint the location
of a radiation source by knowing let's
say you had a gamma ray that entered
detector one so you have your initial
eegammagee a let's draw a couple of
spectra I'm going to use different
colors so I can make them bigger this
will be intensity and this will be
energy so we have our blue detector one
and we have some spectrum for detector
one where we get the photo peak of the
gamma at Iijima and this time you don't
see every possible angle you only see
whatever angle you get that Compton
scatter at or you might see a whole
bunch of different angles nevermind so
you're going to see the Compton edge and
this whole continuum of things and so
you know that whatever energy this
corresponds to means that theta equals
PI that energy corresponds to theta
equals zero and you know that there's a
source somewhere in here
now let's say that photon scatters out
of detector one and into detector two in
this case you've no longer just know
that you have a source of some sort
you'll end up with a certain photo peak
corresponding to this EE gamma prime the
only energy that can Compton scatter in
the direction from
Tector ones a detector to because you
have now determined the angles between
the line between the detectors and the
detector of the source so then you get a
photo peak and the corresponding compton
edge for your agam a prime your A game
of crime that tells you the angle that
it came off of for your first
interaction so that is your source angle
so what that means is that by using
these two angles you've now pinpointed
your source to lie somewhere on these
two cones projected back on one of the
two points were those cones at that
angle intersect this is something I want
you to try and think about and work out
on your own but it's really cool to
explain this because like with one
detector you know that there's a source
somewhere and you know generally where
to point with two detectors and energy
resolution the energy of the photo peak
of the second event tells you what the
angle of the first event was and this
way if you know what source you're
looking for from the first photo peak
and you know what angle you're looking
for from the Compton scattered photons
photo peak because they have those then
you know not only what the source is but
where it is and you know which
containers would take apart to start
looking so this is why we care about
angle because there's actual like real
ways of using this to your advantage to
solve some pretty insane problems like
which container would that be in who's
starting to get the general idea behind
a Compton camera or who would like
another explanation anyone I asked two
questions so who would like another
explanation
yeah okay the idea here is with just one
detector all you know is whether or not
there's a source the only information
you're getting is its photo peak and
Compton edge and Bowl and so you know
the identity of the source
maybe it's cobalt 60 or something but
you don't know where it is by making a
second
you can then determine where on the
Compton spectrum of the first
measurement does the photon lie so by
saying okay the photo peak corresponds
to this energy which corresponds to some
certain angle that this had to scatter
off of so then you know what this angle
is you've determined yes okay angle
you've then determined this angle
because you know the incoming path of
the photon and you now know the outgoing
path which means you know the angle so
if you know the line between these two
detectors and your photo peak lines up
with your first Compton spectrums angle
you then look at that angle back you
also have to sweep around in the other
direction which means you end up with a
cone of possible locations yep
there can be only a couple of things
that could happen right you could have
another direct photon to shoot into
detector - in which case you'll just get
a little bit of photo peak but we know
to expect that so we can ignore it we're
specifically looking for the photo peak
coming from detector one they would
which gives the perfect pretext to bring
up the cross sections for these
processes so I'm gonna skip ahead a
little bit and start getting into what
are the actual cross sections look like
for compton scattering photoelectric and
pair production all of them have to do
with the electron density of the
material the more electrons in the way
the more you get these events happening
so yes you will get compton scatters in
the air because air contains electrons
and they do Compton scatter but air is
not very dense so you will get
comparatively less so let's say that
adds a little bit of noise on the bottom
which is like any detector spectrum
we've ever seen there's always noise
from all sorts of other processes we're
not looking for so now let's start to
look at what the general energy and Z
ranges of each of these effects are and
we're going to recreate one of the plots
that I showed you at the beginning of
yesterday's class so let's make a graph
of energy of the photon and Z of the
material and we want to try to map out
where the following three processes are
dominant so tau our photoelectric effect
C which we'll call our Compton
scattering and Kappa which we'll call
pair production and these cross-sections
do give us relative probabilities as a
function of the energy of the photon and
the medium they're going through along
with the actual density that something's
going to happen so let's look at the
form of these the cross section for the
photoelectric effect scales with Z to
the fifth do you think that
photoelectric effect will be more
likely for lo Z or high Z materials high
Z materials right so we know we're going
to be in the top half area and it's
scales with one over energy to the seven
halves so do you think this will be most
likely with low or high energy so lower
energy so we're gonna fill in our
photoelectric somewhat heat oh I'm sorry
so we know it's going to be in this part
of the Z we know it's going to be in
this part of the energy curve so let's
fill in that area as photoelectric let's
look at the other extreme pair
production it scales with Z squared so
is that going to be in the low or the
high Z area anyone
I think still high just the bigger the Z
the bigger the cross-section right so we
know that pear production is going to be
in the high Z area now how about the
energy it scales with the log of energy
but the energy is on the top so we're a
low or a high energy give you more pair
production high so pair production it's
gonna be here leaving everything else
for Compton scattering and if we jump
back to the start of last class we've
reproduced from the cross-sections the
same sort of plot that we saw before
just from looking at the relative
probabilities of each effect so I think
is pretty cool we can now do that with
some basic physics knowledge the last
thing I want to fill in for Compton
scattering is that the Klein ition a
cross-section which is your differential
cross-section as a function of Omega
combined with the probability that you
scatter into a certain angle and a
certain energy because there's a
one-to-one relationship ends up giving
you your D Sigma C over de which is your
energy distribution of Compton recoil
electrons and that's directly what leads
to this shape right here where if you
have let's say 0.51 MeV relatively low
energy there's let's see what do I want
to say here yeah so as you go up in
higher and higher energy you get fewer
and fewer Compton electrons because like
Jared was saying the probability of a
comput interaction does go down with
increasing energy as we kind of reasoned
out but in addition you get more of
let's say you get relatively more of
these back scattered ones which is kind
of interesting I don't think about that
one but this is the typical shape that
you tend to see for Compton scattering
for lower for high-energy photons you
get a Compton peak and then a very long
shallow tail and as you go lower and
lower energy it starts to sort of
back up yeah Luke oh yeah
the photoelectric effect is an
absorption followed by an ejection in
compton scattering the other photon is
still intact it just loses energy gains
wavelength but the energy of compton
scattering it's let's say four MeV
photons it's on the order of hundreds of
ke V plenty to eject most of the
electrons from an atom so you always
have to think about are you going to
eject something are you above the work
function the work function for most
atoms so we had a nice plot of that is
in the e V range so chances are yeah
Compton scattering mostly is going to be
ejecting electrons - that's the whole
reason we can count them if there wasn't
an electron ejection there would be no
electron ionization cascade to count so
there's some sort of empirical or
experimental proof that it does happen
and speaking of experimental proof you
can actually see that shape in this case
this is a spectrum taken from two
different gamma sources together a what
is it one point two eight MeV and 0.51
MeV you can see that the one point two 8
MeV first of all has a way lower number
of counts showing that the cross-section
does indeed decrease with higher energy
and it doesn't have well you can't
really even see but it does not curving
back up whereas this lower energy
Compton photon is scattering more often
because it's much higher and it's got
that bump back up at the really low
energies so it's kind of neat when the
math that we're looking at if I jump
ahead to the cross sections you can see
that you'd expect the Compton scattering
to decrease with energy and you look at
an experimental plot of two different
energies and there you have it
higher energy less total Compton
scattering but different shape so any
questions before I move on to how you
can use them to design shielding
cool so what we're getting here these
cross-sections are probably better known
to some of you as mass attenuation
coefficients which are simpler ways of
describing how many photons in a narrow
beam would be undergo some sort of
process and be removed from the beam and
they get removed exponentially for the
same sort of reason for pretty much
everything in this class ends up being
an exponential doesn't it where if you
have some if you have some intensity of
photons or some change in intensity
that's proportional to a change in X in
the initial let's see and some what is
it constant of proportionality like the
cross-section or we'll call it now mu
this mass attenuation coefficient the
answer to that ends up being pretty much
the same and it's this simple
exponential thing and the nice thing is
you don't need to be able that you don't
have to calculate all these different
cross sections because they're tabulated
for you by NIST and that's one of the
links on the website on the learning
modules website that I want to show to
you guys now you can actually look up
these total summed cross sections for
gamma ray interactions as a function of
energy versus their mass attenuation
coefficient in centimeter squared per
gram the reason it's in that unit is it
just tells you what the material does it
doesn't tell you how much you have in
the way and that's why I've rewritten
this exponential attenuation formula
with a row on the bottom and a row on
the top that row being the density of
the material because usually you can
just say it's like I naught e to the MU
X but these are the things that you'll
look up in tables and these rows right
here is whatever density you have of
your material so if you want to
calculate how much better cold water is
shielding than hot water because of his
change in density you can then look up
the value for water which I'm going to
show you how to do right now back up to
see the actual site
so if you guys looked right here these
what is it missed tables of x-ray
absorption coefficients I'll show you
how to read through this table now
because you'll need it from everything
from problem set five to the rest of
your life this is like one of those
places you're gonna go constantly
looking for nuclear data so you can
either look at elemental media or
compounds and mixtures water being one
of them so let's go down to water comma
liquid if you notice what's actually
given here is this mu over Rho so the
mass D what is a density specific mass
attenuation coefficient in other words
it's a cross section really it's a
microscopic cross section I don't know
why in a lot of these courses they're
introduced separately because they're
the same thing their interaction
probabilities and then that other row
from the slides just tells you how much
is in the way that Rho times X just
tells you how much water's in the way in
terms of how dense it is and how thick
your water shield is so using these
tables if you know let's say you're
sending in one MeV photon so we look up
10 to the 0 MeV you then have this value
this nice round value of 10 to the minus
1 centimeter squared per gram you then
multiply the die the density of the
water that you have multiplied by the
thickness of your water shielding and
you get the change in intensity of the
photons and let's do an example
calculation just to make it a little
more real so let's say we have a beam of
photons of intensity I not and we're
sending it through a tank of water and
the question is do you want to keep this
water at 0 Celsius or at a hundred
Celsius what's the difference in
shielding between freezing and boiling
liquid water well we can look that up
and let's say we have to specify an
energy of the photons we'll call it 1
MeV photons so we can look up and say at
10 to the 0 MeV we go over we get just
about 0.1
mu over Rho so mu over Rho equals zero
point one centimeters squared per gram
and now we can set up two equations one
for zero Celsius and one for 100 Celsius
so we'll say I at zero C equals I naught
e to the minus 0.1 times Rho at zero
Celsius times X let's say we have I
don't know 10 centimeters of water so
we'll just put a 10 in there that works
out pretty well so and then are I at 100
C is the same I naught times e to the
minus 0.1 times Rho of water at 100
times 10 centimeters and keep in mind
here I made sure that since my new over
row units are in centimeters squared per
gram I'm putting in X as 10 centimeters
because whatever's up here in the
exponential has to be unitless that's a
good check to see why are my
calculations off by a factor of a
billion let's check the unit's in the
exponential yeah
it will change the value of 0.1 will
change depending on the energy of the
incoming photons I know density changes
and that's what we account for here with
this row so next up we have to look up
the densities of water at zero and 100
Celsius so I don't actually know them so
density of water at zero C I'll surprise
surprise it's we'll call it one gram per
centimeter cubed now what is it at a
hundred C too close to tell actually
that's interesting at zero it's a little
lower
no I think that's it sites wrong yeah
let's look at some steam tables because
this is a real place to look for them so
water is a hundred Celsius atmosphere is
okay we'll just see that I think they're
down here
oh the chalks not letting me use the
touchpad that's kind of cool
oh there we go yep I think I got it so
what's the density of saturated liquid
zero point nine five eight zero point
nine five eight grams per centimeter
cubed well actually use the last corner
today awesome so you could actually then
go ahead and calculate because I love
how this worked out right zero point one
and ten cancel of zero point one and ten
cancel so we'll just do e to the minus
one and we get that this I is about
thirty-six point seven nine percent of
the gammas will be transmitted through
ten centimeters of water and here e to
the power of negative point nine five
eight we get thirty eight point three
seven percent transmission so actually
about two percent more of the gammas
will be transmitted if the water is hot
it's a neat little calculation that you
can do now we've looked at a really fine
or very very small magnitude example
folks came to me yesterday saying we
want to design a new type of medical
x-ray apron because we're worried that
people carrying around all this lead are
their backs are hurting and it's like
making surgeons lives difficult if
they're doing radioactive procedures can
we do any better can they do any better
what do you guys think
can you beat physics when it comes to
mass attenuation it's going to be
awfully difficult and the best weapon
you have is these mass attenuation
coefficients to look at their relative
values now these again are in
centimeters squared per gram so this
actually ranks aluminum to uranium in a
sort of like per atom basis it's nut has
nothing to do with their higher
densities which only help things this
just tells you how effective each of
these elements is relatively at blocking
gammas of different energies then to get
the total amount of attenuation you
multiply by the density
aluminum is pretty sparse LED and
uranium are pretty dense there's not too
many ways around this problem in fact I
wouldn't say that there's a way around
this problem the best thing you can do
is look at the really only interesting
features on these curves does anybody
know why there is those jagged edges
there well let's take a look at some
trends for uranium the jagged edge is at
about 110 kV for lead it's like 80 K
evie for tin it's probably more like 50
K evey it's decreasing with Z anyone
remember what sort of magnitude we've
looked at things like this before and if
we're talking about photon and electron
interactions what could be responsible
for those sudden jagged edges
well we have talked before about all
sorts of different decay methods
including those that can eject electrons
from different energy shells you're
looking at the same electron energy
shells if you have a let's say
photoelectric capable photon entering a
calcium nucleus and let's go look at
calcium as an example so I'll go to the
tables of coefficients I'm gonna back up
to elemental media and I'm gonna go to
calcium for a simple example calcium has
got this jagged edge right here and if
we draw a line down it is precisely for
ke V for ke V i bet is going to be the K
edge energy the energy of the most inner
bound calcium electron to find out we
can go to the other NIST page that I
linked you guys to the next X NIST x-ray
transition energy table and let's look
at calcium well this really doesn't work
with chalk on your fingers and let's
look at the K edge to check lo and
behold four point zero five ke V so what
you're seeing here is the photoelectric
peak K edge absorption what this says is
that energy is below 4 ke V you can't
eject the innermost electron you just
don't have enough energy as soon as you
hit 4 ke V those inertial electrons
become accessible to you so the
cross-section suddenly jumps up because
you have more electrons that you can
eject photoelectric Li beyond the 100 ke
V or so there's no more jagged edges
because any photon above 100 kV can
access pretty much energy of any
electron in any element except maybe the
super heavy ones and we don't have this
data for them yet so then you might ask
well there's going to be an L edge for
calcium where would that be
probably off this chart but you can look
up where it would be so we'll go to the
NIST yeah so you had the right idea Dan
it's to the left right yeah exactly so
now let's look up the L edge
so if I were to ask you really doesn't
work with chalk oh yeah okay that's
better
so the l1 edge is down at 438 evey which
is indeed off the scale for this graph
this bottoms out at 1 ke V but if I were
to ask you to draw the full mass
attenuation coefficient for uranium I'd
expect to see a K edge an L edge and M
edge at an N edge corresponding to shell
levels 1 2 3 & 4 and where do you get
that data you get it from here from
these NIST databases or you calculate it
one at a time using that Rydberg formula
where that end final goes to infinity so
you can either calculate them if you
don't know or if miss doesn't have them
in the table and I don't think they have
the N edge wow they go all the way up to
fermium let's do your rhenium what do
they go to yep they don't have the M or
the N edge but you do know how to
calculate them is with that formula and
so if we were to construct any old mass
coefficient good we have the little
space left it's gonna look generally
like this there's going to be a
photoelectric region let's say that's
going to correspond to our photoelectric
cross-section which goes way up with
lower energies there's going to be a
pair production part which goes up with
higher energies and there's going to be
this kind of decreasing Compton
cross-section and if you couldn't dance
these curves you end up with a shape
like that which is just like all the
other mass attenuation coefficients that
you see so this is why they take the
shape that they do if you add up the
cross sections for photoelectric effect
Compton scattering and pair production
and you just kind of bounce on top of
those you end up with the mass
attenuation coefficient the part that's
not shown here is that this
photoelectric effect
we'll have some jagged edges whenever
you hit an electron energy transition
level so it's 505 of I want to see if
you guys have any questions on photon
interactions with matter you know it's a
lot to throw at you at once
but I'm gonna be giving you guys lots to
calculate to try it out and to learn
what's going on from a more hands-on
point of view yeah they're a way to slow
down gammas yeah so the question is can
you slow down gammas without putting
stuff in the way well then what are you
doing
you got a vacuum right there so hmm
that's probably a deeper question that I
think so what else
so gammas for example do have indices of
refraction and materials yeah no gammas
are just photons they're just really
high energy and they do have indices of
refraction that are usually around one
part per million or like 1.000000 one or
so so you can refract or bend gammas
just not very well so the question is
could you do something to stop the
gammas that were maybe ten feet away
the answer is physics not much you can
do but if they are like planetary levels
away it's possible that you could bend
them away from an object just like you
can bend visible light away from
something closer up because it's got a
much higher index of refraction pretty
crazy stuff did you ever think a gamma
rays having indices of refraction and
behaving like regular light it's just
regular light it's just really
high-energy light so any other questions
on the photon interactions would matter
cool
you